[Musique]
17h30 vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines plusieurs milliers
de supporters arrivent pour assister au
choc de d1 féminine entre issy paris et
brest
on est là parce qu on a deux joueurs de
hand et que voilà c'est un événement
dans le coin qui est super sympa donc on
y vient en famille on est content d'être
là du monde il y en avait le match
délocalisé se jouent à guichet fermé
avec 5415 spectateurs dans les travées
cette influence permet de dépasser le
précédent record pour un match de
handball féminin qui était jusqu'ici
détenu par nantes avec 5125 supporters
le record était effectivement une envie
pas forcément l'objectif principal
l'objectif principal c'était de réussir
et vêtements avec tout le territoire et
tous publics
donc ça s'est adjugé je suis très
heureux que ça pour ce premier match de
handball de l'histoire organisé dans
l'enceinte sportive certains n'ont pas
hésité à faire 600 km pour venir
assister à la rencontre et mettre
l'ambiance n'en suis toujours de truquer
peu favori tout avenir le président
rhodanien balle
on essayait de faire les déplacements à
chaque fois qu'on peut mais c'est vrai
que ici dans cette enceinte du vélodrome
c'est parfait se croirait à l'aller
l'adresse ce supporter de brest avait
moins le sourire à la fin de la
rencontre le match s'achève avec une
victoire au forceps d'ici paris contre
les bretonnes sur le score de 24 à 23
selon les joueuses parisiennes l'appui
du public a été primordiale dans ce
résultat une grosse salle bonne ambiance
et je pense que c'est grâce à 55
aujourd'hui on a réussi et franchement
on avait à coeur de bien faire ici sur
le stade vélodrome est montré que le
succès rencontré cette année le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et le club d'issy paris envisage déjà un
second partenariat pour l'année
prochaine cela mérite bien un clapping